معنى اذا حول هذه الاوضاع مراسلنا من مخيم
جنين سميره ابو شماله سمير ضعنا في صوره
اخر الاوضاع في هذا المخيم الذي شهد هذه
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه اليوم واخر
ايضا حصيله لضحايا تلك العمليه
القناصه اسطوح البنايات وقاموا بالاشتباك
مع المقاتلين الفلسطيني الذين تحصلوا الى
جانب خروش واستشهدوا في هذه العمليه
العسكريه خلال الاشتباك المسلح مع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه الجيش الاحتلال دفع
بقوات اضافيه الى مسرح هذه العمليه من عده
محاور اقتحم مخيم جنين ووصل الى هذه
المنطقه وكان هناك اشتباكات مسلح مع قوات
الاحتلال مع المقاتلين الفلسطينيين من
جميع الفصائل وتحديدا من كتائب شهداء
الاقصى وايضا كتائب الشهيد عز الدين
القسام وكثير الجنين التابعه لصلاه الجناح
المسلح لحركه الجهاد الاسلاميه الحصيله
حسب المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه تتحدث عن
سته شهداء سقطوا في هذه العمليه العسكريه
وايضا اضافه الى
جريحا بين الفلسطينيين ثلاثه منهم
الحاله الخطيره وفقا للمصادر الطبيه
الفلسطينيه في هذا المكان ايضا شهد عمليات
مقاومه شرسه من قبل المقاتلين وايضا على
اطراف هذه العمليه كان هناك مواجهات ايضا
مع شبان وفتيه هذا المخيم مع قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه التي ايضا استخدمت
الرصاص وقتلت الفلسطينين بينهم مدنيين
هناك ايضا من الشهداء الذين سقطوا في هذه
العمليه العسكريه خمسه شهداء منهم من
كتائب شهداء الاقصى التابعه لحركه فتح
ثلاثه منهم من كوادر هذه الحركه كانوا
يقاتلون الى جانب احد قيادات
حركه حماس وتحديدا في القسام وهو الشهيد
عبد الفتاح خروشه البالغ 49 عاما وايضا
كانوا يقاتلون الى جنبه ويتصدون لقوات
الاحتلال في هذه العمليه العسكريه في حاله
وحدويه من قبل الفلسطينيين للتصدي لهذه
الاعتداءات انتهاكات والجرائم من قبل جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على الصعيد السياسي
كان هناك ادانا من قبل الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
وايضا وزاره الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه ايذاء هذه الجرائم المتكرره
والمتصاعده من قبل جيش الاحتلال من ناحيه
وايضا ارتكاب الجرائم من قبل المستوطنين
من ناحيه اخرى وهاد تمثل حرب شامله على
الفلسطينيين وقد طالبوا المجتمع الدولي
ترجمه الاقوال الى افعال وذلك بلجم
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عن عدوانه وجرائمه
بحقه الفلسطينيين رئيس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بنيامينه اليهود قد اثنى على
هذه العمليه ورحب بهذه العمليه واثنى على
المقاتلين الذي وصفهم بالشجعان الذين
يقاتلون من اجل التامين الحمايه
المستوطنين والاسرائيليين وايضا
قال وهدد بانه قلبا يحاول تنفيذ هجمات ضد
الاسرائيليين سنصل اليه ونقتله في مكانه
وبالتالي هناك ما زال حاله غريان داخل
الشارع الفلسطيني للرد على هذه الاعتداءات
وهذا ينذر بمزيد من
التوتر الشديد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه خاصه
مع استمرار جيش الاحتلال والمستوطنين في
جرائمه بحق الفلسطينين في جميع الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بما فيها القدس المحتله اشكرك
سمير ابو شماله على هذه الصوره وهذا
المشهد الذي وضعتنا فيها لعمليه اسرائيل
اليوم في مخيم جنين